[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
foreign
yes
[Music]
morning chaps welcome along to the vlog
that chunk up there there
is a piece of one by one five mil steel
which i ordered along with all this
stuff on the floor
when i ordered the treads they were the
treads the angle line were the treads
for the staircase
and the idea is to increase the
dimensions of this little welding table
i mean we've got by with it so far but
now i've changed the orientation of the
workshop
i think we can actually fit a larger
welding table in there
which means that we can reposition this
massive vise
and just have a better workflow around
this area
i'm also going to put the new welding
table on wheels and
everything in the workshop apart from
the built-in stuff like this cabinet
here
will be mobile and we can move them
around if we need to make a bit more
space put them out there
into the brewery space and then bring
them back in when we're finished
so that is a job on the list but it
isn't for today
today's job is going to be to finish off
the staircase which we have nearly done
there's just a few trims to go around
the edge of the
oak flooring and then that is put to bed
i can come
back out of the workshop out of the pub
then
and as you can see the saw's missing
from over here that's next door
we can start to put all these little
bits away and probably start to crack on
with another job
and one of those other jobs is i would
like to make
a mixing paddle for the mash tun
using one of these plaster mixers
relatively cheap
from tool station so if i burn it out
it's not a big expense
the drawback of course is the uh
mixing arm is galvanized steel
no good really for putting in the mash
or
you know having to go through an acid
wash
caustic wash and the like the caustic
will strip the zinc off straight away
so that's something that we cannot do
so i bought some little bits of
stainless steel bar which are down there
at the moment
but we've got like a i think
16 mil shaft and then some 10 mil
smaller pieces of steel which will bend
we'll try and either emulate what we've
got here because this does a
pretty good job of mixing plastic so it
should do a good job of mixing grain
and fail that if it's uh not working
quite as well
we'll weld on some little paddle flaps
or something like that to agitate
the mash a little bit more and we might
even
at some point be expanding this project
to something that can bolt onto the top
of the mash tun
so it wouldn't be at risk of getting wet
because of course if i drop this in
i have to run away of course it will be
it will be situated and uh implemented
via
a ground fault uh gfi
d so where i don't get electrocuted
you know an rcd residual current device
whatever they're called but at the
moment we're going to use it
manually when it's made just got to weld
up the components
and make sure everything fits i wonder
if i could just use
a bit of threaded bar stainless steel
threaded bar
well we'll see we'll come to this
project another time but this is one
that's on the list so i'm just going
over
all the steel that was delivered the
other day and that obviously involves
the new welding table the angle iron for
the treads upstairs
and some stainless steel for a badass
mash tun mixing paddle and the heavens
have opened
oh my goodness well it's a good job
we've got this uh
massive tent that nobody's
enjoying frigging locked down
so as soon as it's freezing cold and wet
outside the rain has stopped now though
i've got a little bit of threaded bar
that we spoke about this morning
we're about to cut it on that little
pencil line
with the grinding disk and i'm going to
set about trying to make
a mixing paddle for the mash tun
hopefully this will work i think we're
going to need some
more bar than what showing i don't know
we'll see we'll see we don't know until
we brew
but what i do know is that i can't find
any
m14 threaded rod to weld onto the end
so we're gonna have to kind of do a
little bit of bodging
and get the original stick here cut it
off around there
weld it onto the new piece so we can
screw it
in and out of the mixer and then
with any look we'll be able to just
spray some lacquer or some liquid galv
on there
just so this doesn't come into contact
with any cleaning fluids
but it shouldn't be a problem because
we'll have just a little top section
there like that
that's going to be going straight into
this bit
so there shouldn't be too much
galvanized
carbon steel on the whole shebang
meaning less risk of rust and thing
so i'm going to set up the grinder we'll
chop this bar off
and then we'll cut down this thin rod
and see if we can bend it into the
correct
shape so i've
managed to clamp the stainless into the
vise
let's bring the original over
so we've obviously increased the size
that goes without saying doesn't it
go big or go home and we managed to
put a bit of a bend on it's relatively
equal but not perfect
in fact it might end up being too big
and then we've nipped these two corners
down here
and made them one
i am worried that we're not gonna have
enough
uh steel but we shall see and then now i
have to try and
reorientate the base section the steel
and put some of these uh
helical flutes into it i don't think
this is going to work out
as symmetrical and as nice as i'd
actually want it to but
fingers crossed we get a bit closer
i'm telling you i'm telling you boys and
girls
that looks a lot better than it did 10
minutes ago
so i think that will do for
a mixing paddle i've got the shaft on
vertical
the tines whilst they aren't bent
perfectly
are pretty damn close to what we had
here previously a lot of fetlin has gone
into that
a heck of a lot but you know what that's
about as close
as you can get with something like that
and there was a point when i was putting
it together that i thought
this is going to end up in the [ __ ]
bucket
but thankfully we pulled through so now
all i have to do i've chopped this
section off the uh the connector for the
mixer we've just got to stick this
up on the top there weld that on
get some of this galv off as well so it
doesn't bother me i'm going to put a
bevel on there so we get a nice tight
weld onto it
um and then go around and fill it until
it comes flush with the rest of the
parent metal
just to give it plenty of strength so
we'll be back
when that's done so you should be able
to see now
both of these tips have been sharpened
like pencil
so when we weld these two pieces
together
we can get right down into the root of
the steel right into the heart if you
think of it as a tree
that means we'll be making sure that
it's as
strong a joint as possible
i have to figure out now a way of
squaring it up i think what i'm going to
do
is stick it in the corner
of a piece of angle iron and of course
that will mean that it's going to be sat
level all the way across uh i'll show
you what i mean i think i've got a
little bit over here
that should be short enough here we are
look
so provided there's no swarf in the
corners
and there does seem to be a little bit
it should sit level so i'll just clear
this swarf out and i'll show you what i
mean
so here's the setup angle iron
clamped both sides which means that this
bar now will run parallel to the angle
iron provided of course with making the
assumption that the angle iron is
straight
and then over here we've got the same
thing
but with the tiny little uh
bolt section just hidden away in there
look
and what we're looking for now this is
tricky because
the diameter of these two are
different so i'm having to kind of bodge
this up a little bit and i am winging it
to provide the right
kind of uh distance here
off the base of the steel in order
for this this is too much up in order
for this to
line up with the center
of that piece of steel there
maybe if i zoom in just a touch more
you'll be able to see
what we're aiming for so there's the gap
and we do want a little gap in between
because we're gonna bridge that with a
bit of steel
and then we're gonna fill the rest of
this
up with filler rod until it's flush with
the parent metal
and hopefully we get a straight
fitting now i'm not going to know
straight off the bat i'm just going to
wing it as close as i can get it
put a little bit of filler in there then
go
over to the machine itself screw it in
give it a few tweaks pull the trigger
ooh
and see how we get on and that's as good
as it's going to get
so i'm going to go and fill this and
hopefully
it comes out exactly how we want it to
complete there we have it i'm trying to
prop up the uh
the camera so we can get some shots here
i don't have a tripod
that's the finished article i haven't
hit it with
a grinder or anything yet or even
cleaned it up
so i hope you can see it's probably not
the best angle to be fair
but i'm limited in what i can do
in terms of propping the phone up
somewhere so
here we go let's screw this bad boy
onto the mixer oh damn i mean i've never
smacked myself in face with it then
not if it's all that right
that is attached that will go into the
mash tun
and that is mixing
[Music]
okay
well if that don't do the trick
i don't know what will there we go let
me uh
take the camera i've actually got it
oh jesus i've got it in the uh
in the vice of all things
but what do you reckon folks mixing
paddle
a harry brew 69
you can probably buy one of these in
stainless steel for 40 quid from bloody
ebay
i know i didn't look surely it's not
going to be a meter long like this one
is
in fact it's longer than a meter but
that didn't cost me a lot in steel
probably about 12 pound in steel for the
stock
and then a little bit of welding and
let's face it
with an argon tank like that
well we can afford to do a little bit of
spot welding here and there but i think
that's fantastic
that concludes today's project well
several projects actually we've finished
the stairs off
we've got this done and uh
that was a project i didn't think i was
going to get to today
now before i go i did want to say a
couple of things
too mainly to mr andrew lynch who's been
watching
um waiting for me to review his
wonderful beers which he was kind enough
to send to me
so we've got the uh well that's the
cider
there this is the hokum stomp oatmeal
porter
and what's this here the elvish juice
dude i'm gonna get stuck into these over
christmas
uh a couple of people know but not many
i've been doing
a bit of a crash diet uh i'm hundreds of
how i was
105 kilograms knocking on the door of 17
stone
and quite frankly i thought it was about
time i shifted a little bit to that
uh so i've been doing this diet and it's
worked
i've dropped quite a few kilograms in
about three weeks
but it's christmas time isn't it and i
actually want to put some videos up of
me reviewing my beers letting you know
what i think of the 12 beers of
christmas
and then also i want to get stuck into
those beers from mr lynch as well
he did send me another one but i shared
it with sam
i don't think we got any of that on
video but we both thoroughly enjoyed it
mate
so look out for some beer reviews of
mine
and of uh andes and
uh have a look at
yeah the website
because we're gonna do a deal we're
gonna do a deal we're gonna do a deal
boys and girls for christmas new year
new year deal so on that note
i'll leave you with a view of the booker
mashton mixer and we'll sign out for now
we will be back with plenty of videos
over the coming period
but i am finishing work
all right i lied you know as well as i
do
i'm gonna get bored one day off and i'll
be in here doing a project honor
we'll see cheers folks i'll see you
oh [ __ ] i've dropped it i'll see you on
the next one